if you had no money no friends
no contacts how would you raise money to
invest in your first
property or how would you get into
property investment
i think what i would probably do is i
would i would start by in business it's
all about finding out what people want
and then giving it to them so i would
just think about how
how can i add value to people so i would
i would probably find i'd get myself
down in
in property circles i'd join business
networking groups i'd go down to
property events i'd find the groups
and i just think what do people need
where are people struggling are they are
they struggling to find deals
they're struggling to find deals are
going to find them a deal are they are
they struggling
um i mean when i started when i was 17
everyone was moaning about property
management companies everyone said oh
managers huh
you know it's as bad as managing
managers as it is managing tenants
that's what everyone was saying so i was
thinking okay these property investors
that i've got a lot of money that own a
lot of houses
i want their crumbs i'm a teenager i
want their crumbs
how can i get in with them how can i
advertise them i know i'll rent their
rooms for free
so i was like i'll manage your houses
and i literally started managing
people's houses for free
i didn't charge any money but i charged
a small admin fee to the tenants you
can't do that anymore
um but i didn't charge them any money
and as a result of that
they're like oh i like this kit ah
everyone starts talking about me
he's a good guy he knows his stuff i was
getting experience
and and then before you know it i'm like
saying to the landlords
you you don't seem to like this property
you keep talking bad about it um why
don't you sell it i
could sell it how about this how about
i'll buy off yeah
i'll give you the price you want but
i'll pay for it on my terms which is
later
and then boom i'm securing lease option
agreements
so i think i think at the end of the day
a business this is a business and money
does not come from property money comes
from people
so it's about finding people's problems
and then finding a solution for that and
as
as you know this might sound common
sense to some people but people forget
that this
money does not come from property i keep
talking about real estate how much i
love real estate but ultimately
if there's no one to live in the house
the money comes from the tenant not the
property
and even if it goes up in value who says
it goes up in value a person
okay so who's actually where am i
getting money from people so
if i was starting all over again i'd
just be thinking right forget me forget
how can i make this money how can i how
can i say
actually how can i find someone
who i can help who's in the property
world and
and and if you if you help the right
people i mean geez they're they're
crumbs they're crumbs could be worth
millions great answer great answer
and you know what everybody who i've
asked that question to
has in one way or another given the
similar answer in the
first of all i would go networking first
of all go and find people
start moving around in the groups that i
want to be involved with
then i would start well you've added a
little bit to that which is good
in that you've said i would find out
what they need fixing that's brilliant
like rob moore for example interviewed
rob moore and he said he would go to
the holiday inn find mark homer start
muscling in there and start getting his
money and start investing right
david siegler said he would go you know
david siegler he would go and
start deal packaging he's like ultimate
deal packager guy
and he would go and find people to
he'd go find deals and find people so
networking again
property is so much networking isn't it
which which i love as well because that
leads me on to another question
in the who inspires you and who do you
relate to
most in property what a question
yeah um i've got a lot of people that
inspire me
you know i've got people that are giants
people like um
you know i i mean i had um the privilege
of having james khan from dragon's den
on my channel
and he's done very well in real estate
as well as business
um you know massive massively
inspirational started absolutely nothing
um yeah i read his book yeah very very
very cool
um and then and then of course you know
i'm very inspired by people like
uh robert kiyosaki is is has been very
much it's been
for me it was actually that book which
dad poor dad
really got me started and i think that's
the case for a lot of people even a lot
of my
friends peers students i'm like what got
you started and they say oh i read
robert kiyosaki's book which dad holder
it kind of opens a lot of people's minds
and so i have to credit him
um i'm addicted to being around people
that are winning
because i think that your environment is
stronger than your willpower and
what i mean by that is is if you're
starting out
again let's say from scratch you can
know all the right things you can read
all the right books
but unless you're around people that are
winning you won't win because
it's it's you just won't you know it's
like when you go for a run i mean
you know i i need a per for me i need a
personal trainer i
i employ a full-time personal trainer
full-time
just because i know i need to be around
i won't motivate myself to go to the gym
every day or to get up and go for a run
i'll come up with excuses but if i'm
just around people
if i've got a personal trainer that's
just coming on holiday with me and
around
that environment is just going to make
just is this going to make it easier for
me so
um yeah there's so many people that
inspires me like
my my students my students inspire me i
have a whole
community a winners on a wednesday every
wednesday i'll get one of my
one of my top performing students i'll
bring them down
i'll interview them and then we have a
whole little club click we go out for
dinners and stuff so
yeah i'm just go and i inspire myself
like just looking at what i've done what
i've achieved my brother inspires me
um yeah